so Congress literally just passed their
spending bill which will take us through
September of 2015 they did this of
course two weeks right before the
holiday knowing that they can just jam
stuff in there at the last second that
nobody gets to read they literally pass
bills constantly constantly that nobody
reads we all know this and they keep
doing it and then sometimes they pass it
and then after oh I didn't read that
thing that was in there but the reason
they do that is so that they can all jam
in their pet projects and pork and all
that stuff without everybody really
knowing anyway so I just saw a list this
literally got passed about an hour ago I
just saw a list of some of the things
that were jammed into this spending bill
it's 1063 pages I assure you your local
congressman and Senator did not read
this thing so let's just a couple of the
things that are now jammed in the
spending bow that really don't have that
much to do with spending or this bill in
general they're blocking new marijuana
legalization bill in Washington
Washington DC so we know voters pass
that now they're somehow blocking at in
the spending bill I don't know exactly
how that's going to work out oh you're
going to love this one wealthy donors
are allowed to give more to political
parties because that's the problem in
America is that rich people don't have
enough influence on our political system
so they're gonna be able to do more
according to the spending bill that was
just passed this was passed more wheat
bread for school lunches well I mean
that's pretty good wheats good i think
we whole wheat that's good right and we
I don't know about wheat is gluten and
something something it's not going to be
good for the celiac disease kids the
sage-grouse faces uncertain future this
has something to do with a certain bird
that's found in some western states the
Republicans think it's going to hurt the
economy if the birds something something
yeah spending bill right just jammed in
no more taxpayer money for expensive
portrait that's pretty good because you
know all these politicians have these
fancy portraits painting all over the
place we're not going to fund that with
our taxpayer money I'm shocked that they
actually that actually will save us a
little money that's pretty good
old-fashioned light bulbs are still
going to be allowed right Republicans
are freaking out because they're forcing
everybody to do these new fangled these
new fangled bulbs well now we're going
to lab the old ones let's see truckers
won't be required to have more sleep I
don't know what that has to do with the
spending bill farmers will get a
reprieve from some clean water rules all
right that basically sounds okay Gitmo
prisoners can't come to the u.s.
can use taxpayer money to engage in
politically risky trades at what does
this have to do is spending I don't know
this is our government Oh America